today we have two very different
keyboards with very different price
points but they both wear the moniker of
a gaming keyboard that is the corsair
k100 and the msi vigor gk20 both of
these will be available to purchase
using the links in the description down
below but it's about time we ask which
one is the most worth it
the vigor gk20 is definitely on that
cheaper end of the spectrum but has a
few features that go beyond your
standard no frills keyboard it's aimed
at the kind of budget gamer or someone
who's just dipping their toes into the
world of pc gaming but i suppose wants
the rainbow aesthetic that goes along
with the hobby firstly it is a membrane
keyboard but don't hold that against it
too too much of course it's not got any
of the fancy nice high response switches
but at this price point you can
obviously see why that being said for a
membrane keyboard it really doesn't
actually feel that bad to use it still
retains quite a bit of tactile and
audible feedback through each keystroke
way more than i expected a membrane
keyboard to ever have the gk20 has a
fairly lightweight plastic shell and is
usable both flat and raised but
personally i didn't find it to be the
most comfortable device in either
configuration although your mileage may
vary but at least the legs were raisable
vertically meaning that i could move it
around my workstation without fear of it
buckling over like my hardware was in a
drunken stupor and using the awkward
drunken analogy to talk about fluids
msi do say that the keyboard is liquid
resistant to up to 60 milliliters of
splash that means whatever toxic gamer
fluid that you're drinking isn't gonna
do too much damage to the keyboard when
you inevitably spill it and since it's
got a drainage channel so all that muck
doesn't stay in the keyboard that makes
it easier to protect when you inevitably
spill something gross on it and way
easier to clean which is nice because
i've seen some of your keyboards out
there and they are absolutely ming it
clean your keyboards all right it's
gross and continuing with the gaming
theme of the board i don't think it's
actually legal anymore to put gaming
on a device without it having some form
of rgb
even if it's the basic rgb that comes on
the gk20 it features a fixed rainbow
lighting effect that you can switch
between steady breathing and off but
because those lights are pushing away
through the underlying membrane rubber
the effect you end up with is much more
of a pastel aesthetic rather than the
brighter colors you might see on other
devices but hey some people might prefer
that vibe like i said though the options
being on off breathing the inability to
actually change any of the colors means
it is pretty basic and that is a theme
that carries throughout the entirety of
device
it's basic it has some basic
anti-ghosting on
pretty much just the keys that matter
that being where your left hand sits
when you're playing games as well as
some again very basic multimedia
function controls it's not going to be
the fastest or most responsive device
you're ever likely to get your hands on
but it's also not something that's
advertising itself on the back of giving
you a competitive edge in games or hyper
fast response times or really high
performance keys and utilizing only a
usb 2.0 the gk20 very much
knows its own lane but is basic always
bad i don't think so with its fewer
functions it means that it's only going
to take up one usb slot on your computer
and with its limited rgb lighting
there's no extra software some people i
think are actually going to prefer
that plug-and-play no frills approach
and for 40 bucks
you can't really ask for much more than
that
but what if we bumped up that price of
230 dollars you'd understandably expect
a lot more right well with the corsair
k100 you do get a lot more bang for your
buck corsair describes the k100 as the
centerpiece of your setup i can't lie it
is a bit of a looker obviously the first
thing people are likely to notice is
that the rgb offerings are a whole lot
more in depth each key is individually
lit and the whole device is surrounded
by 44 zones of strip lighting on its
three visible sides casting whatever
wonderful lighting sequence you
programmed onto the rest of your
workstation now those keys as gorgeous
and as well as they are obviously differ
a lot to the keys in the previously
mentioned gk20 and they're in fact the
first keys of this type that i've ever
used the model that i've had my hands on
utilizes corsair's own opx optical
mechanical switches that means rather
than relying on a traditional mechanical
key these switches use a beam of
infrared light to register actuation the
advantage of this is that the registered
key presses are much more precise can be
much more sensitive and a zero d bounce
meaning that you can really hammer those
buttons as fast as your thumbs and
fingers can carry you now i must say the
keys on this thing felt so
satisfying to use especially after
coming from a membrane keyboard of
course i say that the k100 can deliver
inputs up to four times faster than
other gaming devices now i'm not sure
what gaming devices in specifics they
mean but i can tell you i felt a lot
more fluid and responsive after bringing
out the k100 it's incredibly responsive
and performs exceedingly well through
whatever game i put it through or during
intense typing sessions where i'm trying
to hammer out a script hours before
deadlines but i have two issues one
being that the sensitivity of these keys
does play to their impressive response
time it does mean that any tiny tickle
that you give the keyboard is going to
register a key press to the point that
there were some moments where even just
resting my hand on wasd like any real
gamer does sent my word documents into
fits of wazzed while i was trying to
culminate a thought but using the
included comfy memory foam palm rest
does help take some weight off of those
keys and after a few days i did find i
was getting used to that sensitivity i
promise you though this isn't the second
video where i'm blaming an issue on my
fat hands
because the other problem that i was
getting cannot be solved with a palm
rest or
reducing the size of your sausage
fingers and that is the ping that comes
from the aluminium chassis whenever
you're typing on the keyboard while it's
shell provides that beautiful sleek and
sturdy exterior i found that during most
keystrokes with the return key and
spacebar being major offenders the
keyboard will talk back to me with a
resonating ping
while you can drown the sound out with
your gameplay or headphone users won't
really be bugged by it once i noticed it
i found i was hearing it all the time
it's a shame because otherwise this
thing feels like a really great high-end
piece of kit
but what might be a minor issue really
started to grind at me after a few hours
and now i can't really hear it and for
the price point of this thing it's not
the kind of issue you'd expect to have
and now we get onto all the other bells
and whistles that feature on the face of
your board the first being core says iq
control wheel i kind of thought it
seemed like a bit of a weird gimmick at
first but once i got to toying with it a
little more i started to love this
little round widget by default you can
control things like the brightness of
your keyboard switch through
applications scrub through audio tracks
or zoom in on web pages but if you
actually delve into the software and
program it yourself you can get this
thing to do pretty much
anything you can think of it's another
one of those weird wrinkles on hardware
devices that you get more out of it the
more you actually put into it one of my
go-to's was that i could dash through
video timelines when i was editing in
adobe premiere and with a little
tweaking i could even bring the
functionality into some of my games and
while it definitely wasn't designed this
way
i it was it's just really nice to fiddle
with there's there's definitely zoom
meetings where i'm looking down just
playing with a random thing it wasn't a
design like that corsair didn't put that
there for that reason but it's it's like
you get a free fidget toy
on top of everything else but going back
to explore this keyboard's extensive
functionality it also features a full
side of six macro keys that are not only
programmable to whatever macro you
desire but can also function as a mini
elgato stream deck allowing integration
with elgato software and can be mapped
to any function inside your streaming
software or for controlling your twitch
streams and considering stream deck
minis are at least 80 to 90 and these
six keys nestled nicely onto the side of
your keyboard have much of the same
features i think that streamers and
content creators are really going to dig
them i tried them out in some of my
personal streams and actually found that
for some instances i preferred those
keys over the stream deck that sits on
the other side of my desk
when i wanted to add some rapid flare
they were just a small couple of inches
away but they're not close enough to the
rest of the keyboard that during frantic
moments of gameplay you're going to
accidentally reach over slap a g key and
end your stream although to make full
use of all these features is going to
take up two usb 3.0 ports in the back of
your rig with one 2.0 on the keyboard as
a pass-through and you will have to
install both corsair's iq control
software
and the elgato stream deck software i
know having more programs to run can be
frustrating to many users out there but
the saving grace is that both of these
programs are thankfully very easy to use
and in my experience work together with
really no issues from the payoff being
getting even more functionality out of
this already really feature-rich
keyboard
they were installs that i was more than
happy to make but beyond these extra
doodads for you to play with you also
get the same dedicated media control
keys that have been standard on many of
corsair's previous offerings some of
them duplicate what you can get the
control wheel to do but having more
options at your fingertips has been a
welcome bonus and hasn't left the piece
feeling too bloated
but does all of this warrant the hefty
price point for the corsair k100
i think it might going back to the vigor
gk20 it's not going to be a tournament
winner it's not for esports wannabes
it's entry level but it is a decent game
aboard for the budget of around 40 bucks
giving credit to corsair's claims the
k100 does
truly feel like a centerpiece it's the
most feature rich and probably the best
performing keyboard i've ever used and
will probably be my daily driver for a
good while personally when it comes to
keyboards i prefer the higher end
because it's something that you're going
to use for a while keyboards are going
to last you a good number of years so in
my mind it makes sense to invest in
something you're going to really enjoy
using for a good while the strange
metallic ping that you get from this
thing is is really annoying but over the
sounds of your game your music having
your headphones on you're not going to
notice it and while the keys did take a
little while to get used to once i did
actually get to grips with them i found
them really light really responsive
they're really nice to use if you choose
to invest into the high price point of
the k100 it will remain your centerpiece
device for some time it's certainly
going to sit comfortably on my
workstation for a good good while and
with all the functionality you get all
the utility it's high performance it's
really really satisfying to use
i do think that the k100 really is worth
it
but those are my thoughts on these two
very different gaming keyboards that are
going to attract two very different
types of gamer but if you've used either
of them let me know your experiences in
the comment section down below if you
like the sound of either of these
keyboards you can find purchasing links
in the description if you enjoyed the
video make sure to like leave a comment
subscribe for more videos like this one
and i will see you next time
[Music]
you